[音楽]
さてごにアメリカ行きますか行ってあり
ますかあんたなんでいいのよ来ちゃだめよ
えこれは遡ること1週間前もうおれなん
です私たちは家を
なくしホームレスになってしまいましたあ
そのスイッチもメルカリで売れたわお金お
金
おいふざけんなよいい加減働け私には働く
のなんて向いてないわ俺がお母さんに
ぴったりな仕事持ってきたからはあ政府が
募集してたスパイ活動アメリカの豪邸に
ガードマンとして潜入しこの悪い大富豪が
持ってる分解遺産のティアラを盗る
ことめんどくさ転売の方が儲かるわこの
テアは元々日本のものだっただがこの大
富豪が盗んだらしいちなみに独身で女優
好きほほ政府はアメリカと問題を起こさず
何としてでもこの手洗を持って帰りたいだ
からスパイを雇った期限は2ヶ月だから
やんないわよ報酬はだからやんないって
1億円やる私が日本のために立ち上がるの
よお母さん俺のチケットはあんたの
チケットは転売したわさアメリカン
ドリーブ掴むわよサボらず2ヶ月で
ちゃんと
やれよ
ここに潜入してティアラを盗めってこと
ねあそういえば屋根ちゃんから自動を
もらってた
[音楽]
わテストでいい績を残さなければ君には
帰ってもらうはい握力のテストだこれで
最低100km出さないと難しいな何人が
このテストに落ちてことかこんなおばさん
が絶対
わ
さ5格
だ素晴らしいじないか気にいた
[音楽]
よ豪邸
だち
はあ今日からこの家のガードマンとして
トーマス様の身の安全を守ってもらう今日
からよろしく
[音楽]
とい特にこのティアラは絶対に盗まないよ
なこれがティアラ綺麗だちょ
ま再セタの防犯警備をけてるから誰も盗み
はしない
[音楽]
さ
俺の家族を見てけしやがって
わわ
すごい素晴らしいよこれ今月の給料よ
ねお金だち
てこの貧民の民族が敷をよす
な俺の全てを奪った恨み死ぬか切いてわら
なううわ
もらったお金でレストランに行ってみます
アメリカのご飯楽しみだなワックワク
いらっしゃい
ませ
よいしょしかしこれいくらぐらいなん
だろうこれで適当に作って
[音楽]
はーい
お待たせしましたおいし
そう
ああ
あんおいしいお待たせしましたうんお待た
せしましたお待たせしましたお待たせし
ました
へえ幸せな
[音楽]
ち
アメリカ
[音楽]
最高その後も私は楽すぎる仕事をこなし
最高の生活を送ってい
たマ出てきなさいあなたのせいでこの町は
貧困になったのよはい
はいあ
なんだこのおばさシアア英語もちょっと
上達したご飯
[音楽]
ご飯あれ最後の1枚かまじゃこれであ
なはい
あちちちゃちっちゃ
ち
はあしっかしお金がなくなっちゃった
なあれ私ってなんでここに来たんだっけ
ああ私テア盗に来たんだったしかもあと1
週間急がなきゃ急がなきゃ急がなきゃ急が
[音楽]
なきゃ
ち
早いとこ盗んで金稼いで帰るわ
[音楽]
よ
お楽笑
ね
ん
[音楽]
ちちちちやってん
だお前まさか盗もうとしたんじゃない
だろうななんだその格好はえっとネズミ
ちゃんがいたんであのばれないようにと
思ってこの黒
でやめろお前は最近怪しいと思ってたんだ
首だ今回は
度目はな
あちゃまずいわ本当に無理かもしれないわ
こんな時に屋根ちゃんがいれば
ないるよちゃんおさん任務のれるとって
ついてきたんだ
[音楽]
よこの時のために監視カメラを少しずつ
ずらして準備しておいたんだやねちゃんお
願いながら手伝っていいけどスイッチ
たくさん買ってよね任せ
なさ作戦はこう
だ明日トーマスの好きなハリウッド女優の
ジュリーガーンを招待し
そこでまずティアラを試着させるこれは
日本の国なですすごい高そうジュリさんの
頭が寂しいわつけてあげましょうよけてみ
たい
わお似合い
ですその際にそいつのアレルギーである
みかのシを飲み物に
入れる
[音楽]
そして気持ち悪くなったジュリーを女子
トイレに連れて
行くあたら入んなよ女の子のど女の子の
私人でしょ女子トイレにはお母さんしか
入らないように
するそこで俺が作った偽のティアと本物の
テアを交換
する引っ張る力強すぎだろ何やってんだよ
あのおば
さん
おいジなんだろなろおい大丈夫
か
な女の子のそうなのよがすごいなってる
よちょっとあんたもどっか行きなさいよさ
行きなさい
よおいはいはい高のクルも一を調べさせろ
はい
はいまずいわこのままだと私のポケットに
ある本物のティアラ
がなんて
ね大丈夫でしたほらジュリーさんが大変だ
からパーティーはお日にしましょう作戦
通りこのフのティアラを挟んでおいたのよ
屋根ちゃんが監視カメラをずらしてくれた
おかげで資格になり見つかることはない
の私はお片付けしてくる
わ
およしいいぞ最後は監視カメラに見つから
ないようにティアラをゴミ箱に入れ
てこれでいつでもテアが取り出せる
お母さんよくやったな
[音楽]
きこ
今まりありがとうもうきこの日かいいいえ
それじゃ私はゴミ出して日本に帰ります
[音楽]
ねどう
も
うんこれはどうやら偽物のようだ
ああどこかに私を売切たものがいるようだ
あ
あ笑えるだろの価値だこのクソ泥本物は超
小型GPSがついてるの
[音楽]
ださあ見るがよいそのGPSの位置
をえどうやらと犯はkmのとにいるよう
[笑い]
[音楽]
だ今からつまに行く君は帰っていい
ぞ行く
ぞあありがとうござい
[音楽]
ますそんな仕掛けがあるだろうと思って
ハッキングをしてGPSの位置を変えて
おいたよすごいわやねちゃんさすがよ
1億円ゲットだねスイッチ買ってよねマナ
ラン
[音楽]
ですここが新しいお家ですうわすっげえ
あれスイッチはないですは一億系は1億
なんで全部使ったわよもうあんたその辺で
遊んで
なさいふざけん
なということで日本に帰ってきました
ただいまただいま僕たちバンカラジは2
ヶ月間アメリカに遊学をして勉強してまし
た今後サブチャンネルではその留学の様子
も上げると思いますそしてスタジオも
大きくなったちゃうわあすげえ
おお
お
おあれこれ何かしら
お母さんそれはね超ハレベルでやばすぎる
間違い探しだよそしてなんと本日より
Amazonで予約開始ですこんな感じで
間違い探しで遊びながら非認知能力が
そらすような本を作りました間違い探しの
数はなんと200個もあって小学生から3
歳そして大人の人が解いても難しくてりえ
のある問題がたくさんあります
ジジーバンカラジオのシールもついてくる
よそして前回のあの1000人以上が来た
大成功の
ポップアップトースター
日程は2024年の1月27日と28日の
2日間東京と大阪の書店で行いますこちら
の方税込みで130円で販売しているの
ですがなんと約400円プラスしたら
1650でお渡し化イベントで私たちの
ジスサイボをお渡しして30秒も離せて
しかもポストカードももらえるんです得
すぎ店員は東京と大阪それぞれ選択300
名です今から下の概要欄からこちらの本の
単体のURLそしてイベントのURLも
貼ってますぜひそちらからチェックして
ください今すぐい今すぐぐいねということ
で是非本当に会いたいって方はね早めにご
購入お願いしますはい僕らも皆さんと
会えるのを楽しみにしてますGGえそして
今後のバンカラジオの活動なのですが少し
投稿頻度を落として活動していきたいと
思いますもっともっとコメディの
クオリティを上げて世界中の子供たちに
楽しんでもらえるようなコメディを作って
いきたいと思ってますそのためにねもっと
勉強しなきゃいけないなっていうのを感じ
たしもっとね英語も勉強していきたいなと
いうことでコツコツ勉強しながら動画を
あげていきたいなという風に思ってます
投稿頻度は少し落ちるけど1つ1つの動画
は絶対にパワーアップして皆様に楽しんで
いただけるように頑張るので皆さん期待し
ておいてくださいじゃえじゃここからも
コメディ頑張りましょうね頑張ろう
よしこれからもバンカラジオも応援
よろしくお願いしますよろしくまたねバイ
バイ買ってねちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル
登録チャンネル登録チャンネル登録
よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル登録
チャンネル登録よろしく最はグチャンネル
登録チャンネル登録チャンネ
登録